je ne veux pas que tu touches aux boîtes
aux lettres comme ça je te mettrai une
boîte de grands noms zéro risque zéro
risque voilà une formule qui résume
assez bien la doctrine mise en place par
michel petit pour preuve avant de nous
accueillir dans sa commune le maire nous
a donné quelques recommandations
il nous a été demandé de respecter des
conditions assez drastiques comme le
port de sète sur blues du masque
évidemment pour rencontrer donc ce mr
particulièrement précautionneux
il faut dire que avant d'être le maire
de cette commune d'un peu plus de 500
habitants
michel petit et avant tout pharmacien de
formation depuis le début de l'épidémie
michel petit a distribué plusieurs
circulaire à l'attention de ses
administrés le but sensibiliser tout le
monde sur les gestes à adopter
on doit changer tous nos gestes
habituels et on a des habitudes
même moi j'ai parfois les des
difficultés à les appliquer je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est bien ancrée c'est
bien ancrée dans l'est et dans les
esprits une mission que michel petit
assure en tant que maire mais aussi en
tant que pharmacien
nous le retrouvons devant son officine
le voici en pleine discussion avec un
médecin de la région
dès que je les ai je te préviens si tu
veux du soluté hydroalcoolique on en
arrache particulièrement vigilants et
précautionneux michel petit lait aussi à
l'intérieur de sa pharmacie alors dans
l'officine
il y a trois fils 2 pour les patients
une pour les professionnels de santé
c'est-à-dire les infirmières ou les
médecins qui viennent au quotidien
l'homme a le matin des distances à
respecter de 1 mètre 50
et vous voyez ici les gens ne peuvent
pas poser leur sac ou hot sur les
comptoirs c'est pour ça que nous avons
mis des balises
on pourrait dire que c'est un excès de
zèle mais moi je pense aux personnes qui
sont vraiment offrons aux urgentistes
qu'on médecin réanimateur aux
infirmières il n'y a pas besoin de
surcharge de travail certes rassurés par
les mesures de précaution prises par le
maire les habitants du village restent
toutefois inquiets
au-delà de l'aspect sanitaire c'est
l'impact économique qui est dans tous
les esprits
nous par la force des choses on a mis
pratiquement 80% notre personnel un
arrêt on devra également avancé les
salaires du mois d'avril
le souci étant c'est que les avancées
oui quand on n'a pas de trésorerie
c'est bien nous on en a un petit peu
donc on va pouvoir assurer un accès
avril mais après on ne sait pas parce
qu'on connaît pas du tout les délais
aujourd'hui de remboursement de 2 c de c
avant ce qu'on va faire sur le chômage
partiel
on a perdu énormément
au niveau de notre activité on faisait
des prestations un traiteur qui sont
totalement allumés au jour d'aujourd'hui
donc on s'est rabattu sur notre activité
de boucherie c'est pas évident avec le
confinement
parce que nous on fait les marchés tous
les jours dans les mines et sur le
secteur d'arras tous les marchés ont été
annulés aussi alors je vous l'accordé
image de la commune de berles au bois
vidée de ses habitants c'est un peu
moins saisissant visuellement que les
champs elysées vidées de leurs touristes
mais pourtant ici aussi les mesures de
confinement sont respectés ont un impact
sur la vie quotidienne des habitants
aucun cas de colis de 19 n'a pour
l'heure été détectée ici mais dans les
communes avoisinantes il ya des
personnes qui ont été testées positives
et malgré toutes les mesures de
précaution prises par le maire du
village
il attend à ce qu ici aussi des
personnes soient touchées par cette
épidémie